5 26 into Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well there's good news
and bad news at the 95 515 and
Charleston
first the good news after being closed
for about a month that ramp from
Charleston to go north on the 95 515
that's scheduled to reopen Friday
evening around 7. now the bad news
starting next Monday morning the Nevada
Department of Transportation is going to
be shutting down the exit ramp from the
southbound 95 515 to get on to
Charleston now just like the entrance
ramp that's about to reopen the exit
ramp will be closed for about a month
with no exit at Charleston you can get
off beforehand at Eastern or afterwards
at Boulder Highway it's all part of the
ongoing ndot project to not only widen
the freeway ramps but also to add a lane
to the 95 in that area buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation by emailing traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com